aside from bread one question we got
asked at every show every show was our
opinion of the one piece live action
which by the time this has come out
should have come out about two weeks ago
yeah 3 weeks ago maybe two or three
weeks ago yeah um well I I got one
episode left to watch oh yeah so I've
watched seven episodes okay cuz I've
I've only seen the first two and I'm
saving the rest for of it for my flight
back I've watched it all so yeah it's
Eight Episodes right it's Eight Episodes
yeah uh yeah it's
fun and that's that review thank you
much that's that segment everyone listen
like I I'm watching it and I'm having a
good time but it it's like I'm not like
desperate to keep watching did you get
what I mean like I don't feel you feel
like that's because you already are into
one piece I think there's definitely
part of that I would love to be able to
watch it with a fresh perspective cuz I
feel like it's way easier to go from
that to the the manga rather than vice
versa yeah yes totally cuz like
obviously I have preconceived notions of
segments I really liked and when they
changed them I was like oh yeah why yeah
it's it's it's hard to get rid of that
so like yeah I think I think like
honestly this is honestly like one of
the best liveaction adaptations I've
ever seen I think yeah as an adaptation
it is 10 out of 10 as a standalone TV
series which I think is important to
judge like not just as an adaptation I
think it's like a fun seven or eight out
of 10 show I'd say I would give the
entire one piece live action like an
eight or 7.5 maybe live action for Live
Action uh like I don't feel like I could
show it to normies no actually I don't
think I I think I think I I think okay
here's here's the thing proper normies
yeah yeah no no okay this is this this
showed me the one piece live action
showed me the power of like why people
are trying to make liveaction anime
adaptations uh so like I get like I get
a message from my cousin before the show
and he's like the biggest [__] norie
of all time you know what I mean and
it's not just him uh his wife as well
yeah both totally like uninterested in
anime at all and I get a message being
like Oh I know this is totally like non
anime but we watched the one piece live
action we uh we're actually like not
just me but my wife as we're actually
really interested in getting into the
anime uh and uh good [__] luck with
that and uh I was talking to Sydney's
brother as well who you know is is is
more of a nerd but definitely not the
anime type of n you know uh he watched
the one piece live action and he was
like [__] I did not think I would enjoy
that but that was really good oh maybe D
maybe I just have too maybe I'm too you
know we've had to hide in the shadows
with so long anime fans be very careful
about which the preconceived notion of
like oh the live action is for the anime
fans only right but I I think that's
like so like watching live action I
think there's two amazing things that
they did uh one was obviously I think
like one of the biggest weaknesses was
you know there are some moments
especially I think during our Long Park
that don't hit as hard as they did in
the original anime or manga yeah and you
know I I think I think like in my
personal opinion arong the arong park
Arc needed maybe an extra episode just
to really flesh out dude I just kind of
did you feel like other segments had too
many episodes I yes I felt like Uso AR
had one too many
episodes I felt like AR Long Park could
have used that extra episode because
that was like one of the hardest hitting
moments I mean it wasn't like the moment
was bad it just definitely did not hit
as hard as it did in the anime or Manga
just because there was way less screen
time uh but you know you still had the
important moments and everything like
that uh Sanji having a British accent
took took me by surprise urised not
going to lie like a London accent I was
like well I did not expect that for
sanj sanj he's kind of he's kind of like
that what you mean my cooked bad I
really like that though no I I like God
being
Scottish just like I think it all like I
actually like the casting I actually all
en I there's not a single casting I
didn't enjoy yeah I thought all of them
were pretty spot on I also like the fact
that they didn't resort to using like uh
you know high-profile actors and
actresses as well I also like that there
was a lot of um a lot of the it looked
kind of goofy at times but a lot of them
were like just uh like practical effects
for the costumes like they were like
like arong looks [__] weird but he
would look weird so I'm kind of glad he
looks [__] weird the best way I can
say it which is one amazing thing that
they did is despite how [__] Goofy
and stupid all the character designs are
they never felt like anime you know they
they they felt like they some of them
felt anime I mean they always felt like
they existed in its own fictional world
right it didn't it didn't feel like it
didn't feel like I was watching like a
Japanese live action anime adaptation
where was just like everyone try to act
like anim they try to act like anime
characters I just felt like these just
were goofy characters in a goofy World
it almost felt like you know how I have
you guys ever seen like a stage play or
something like that of course yeah so
you know how when you're watching a
stage play you have you have props that
are meant to represent something and you
know it's not like a [__] wood set
it's just a simple stage set or a prop
that is just give meant to give you the
idea that's what it felt like you knew
that these practical effects and these
like makeup effects you knew that it
doesn't it doesn't exist in the real
world but they sold it enough that in
your mind you kind of like you allowed
your suspension of disbelief to really
go into this fictional world uh because
one of the thing I really think that the
one piece live action did correctly was
really sell you on the whole world of
One Piece you know this fictional World
building of one piece with like all of
these different factions the fishmen and
everything as well is I didn't realize
how I won't lie it it did piss me off
after a while where he kept saying I'm
going to become king of the Pirates when
you read it it isn't that annoying but
he said it like every two minutes and I
was like okay I get it I get I get it I
get it luy I get it I get it that it's
your thing and you do this a lot but my
God stop and also there was there was a
few moments uh like again like I think
it was it it was it did a lot of amazing
things and it was really fun there were
a few moments where the dialogue really
did take me out of it for a moment and I
felt like it could have been a little
bit better oh [__] I was watching
episode 6 and it felt like it there was
like I can't remember there was one
scene where they like I think they were
around the bed and there was just this
scene where it felt like they were all
just talking separately and they weren't
talking to each other and it was really
weird NPCs it was very bizarre it was
like a really weird conversation because
there was some other conversations that
were really good like every GARP scene I
I kind of I thought that it was kind of
interesting how they did this dialogue
um but and there's also uh did you see
that when I watched it I thought it was
a weird transition and then I'm so glad
that someone posted it on Twitter and
thought this was a weird transition cuz
I felt so validated there's a transition
where they did with like a with the go
board oh I remember that and it was so
[__] weird they did a transition
where they put a piec on the go board
and then the go piece transitioned into
Luffy's hat top down it was a very Jank
transition and then they also walked on
their Mark kind of weird like Luffy
didn't start walking until someone
walked next to him so like to say his
Market it was kind of weird they it was
just it was a very nitpick but it was
those kind of things that like kind of
you kind of get like for a moment like
oh yeah this is okay this is a show yeah
you know those are very very very slight
nitpicks but I think I think I think
it's you when you watch a show like this
and everyone's getting so hyped around
it I think it is fair to be like hey
there it's okay to have some things you
didn't like and concerns cuz I I do feel
like there were so many micro decisions
that I noticed that maybe not a lot of
people noticed that I think really
worked well yeah there's some very good
quality of Life Changers yeah like I
felt it was [__] genius to have only
certain characters shout out attack
names right right because I think there
is only Luffy buggy and at the end Sanji
who shouts out attack names and it all
felt in character like like you know you
know like cuz I was wondering I was
wondering when I was watching the
trailer if people shout out attack names
it's going to be cheesy as [__] but you
know when Luffy shouts out when buggy
shouts out I'm like all right you know
that's it's because it's it's because
it's Luffy and character yeah yeah but
any everyone else is just like it's just
a normal fight scene I thought that was
[__] genius cuz I I don't know if I
could you know like maybe take Zoro
seriously if he was
like with like the [__] sword in his
mouth and like
uh yeah I I my I guess my now that I'm
I'm really done with it and I'm like I
would like to watch more my concern is
how do you make more how how do you make
Chopper okay a lot of characters a lot
of fights that get really weird really
bizarre and I feel like the start of one
piece is when it's most adaptable in
terms of one toone live action simp CU
it's still it does the gum you know the
gum gum [__] is weird but I me that they
clear they did a great job animating
that stuff but how when it gets really
[__] weird also it's long we these
characters are going to get old the ACT
is going to get old the budget is crazy
like how do you how do you go about this
I would like to see more as well that's
why I actually really hope that I want
more yeah I I definitely want more
because I feel like they would give a
little more time now now that they know
that it is a success it is popular uh
especially when it gets Alabaster that
that gets the like more than two
episodes was it like seven million on
average an episode was it sheh do where
didd you get that from I don't know I
saw it I can we fact check is how much
what was the budget I guess I guess I
guess to answer your question while
we're checking uh one thing that I was
actually like very impressed with uh in
terms of like the writing which was like
I was so scared of going into the one
piece live action is uh I call it
[__] Marvel syndrome where 1727
million per episode per million for
theas I mean okay that's that's a we'll
get Marvel that's a lot of money um the
level of success that it needs to
sustain that is good I think it's got it
I think it's it's it it's proven that
it's value in it yeah uh the set design
was insane yeah I mean I just hope that
they can keep the budget going and the
show can keep popping off cuz I again I
want to see more of it yeah because like
I was like as I was saying I think I
think the reason why the goofiness kind
of worked was like it didn't do this
thing which I think a lot of Hollywood
films and especially Marvel movies do
where you know when like something weird
happens especially like there's a
there's a thing in like Ant-Man uh the
new Antman where one of the characters
looks [__] like atrocious like an
Abomination and the entire joke is just
everyone laughing at how stupid this guy
looks look at this big guy with this
like wide face it's so funny uh and
considering how many weird things happen
in one piece there was never a sing
moment where the joke was wow this is
that just happened that was weird I just
saw a clown yeah they never they never
pointed out they never pointed it out
and that yeah that like that that look
at that look at
that they always like they trusted the
joke they had faith in it yeah and like
think like subconsciously because none
of the characters felt it was weird I
didn't think it was weird cuz no one
pointed out how weird it was so I was
like oh this is just normal to exist in
this world so even if something things
looked outplaced none of the characters
really Drew attention to it so I didn't
draw attention to it and I thought that
was [__] genius in terms of the
writing yeah I hope we get more I hope
it doesn't take forever obviously
there's a a lot of strikes going on
right now so we're probably not going to
you know going to be for a while which
sucks cuz I I wonder if they're going to
have to do like a James Cameron approach
where you film as much of it now while
the actors are all still young cuz oh my
God this is this is going to be if they
do it if they film it as they're like I
guess reaching it it'll be like what
like 15 years well how long did the one
piece live action take for production
again it was like I don't know two two
years two three years I think I think it
was longer than that I meanly it's like
four or five
years apparently the script's ready the
next one oh really but they just need to
the the strikes need to be agreed
devices and stuff which obviously uh
means that it you know it's uh we're not
going to see it for a while uh which
kind of sad cuz I I the one thing that
kind of sucks about current TV is that
because they have to wait to see how how
a show does we often have massive gaps
between season 1 and two of shows
because that you know back in the day
they'd be like oh yeah this is a good
pilot give it 900 episodes yeah uh you
know so you get a lot and it was it was
good yeah late 2024 early 2025 that
means early 2025 for sure there's no way
that definitely means early 2025 at
earliest there's no way yeah so we're
going to have to wait like 2 years until
so I don't know if this is a hot take it
might be a hot take okay I think I know
you're going to say that the one piece
live action is a better introduction
than the anime okay wait do you okay
does this include the
manga it
does it does not a big thing to say be
very careful I have to be careful but I
think theime that's the anime is fine to
say that cuz I think a lot of people
agree that the anime is extremely slow
it starts and the pacing is the main
issue and the reason why lot people get
turned off and I think this is a I mean
the fact that we get through 10 volumes
in what doesn't feel like too long okay
uh so yes if I knew the person was an
anime fan or like already into like
anime and manga I would recommend the
manga but if it's someone who maybe has
no interest in anime or Manga I would
actually recommend the live action over
any other one piece media to get them
into the world of One Piece how many
episodes does it take for them to finish
allong Park in the anime 52 yeah yeah
it's a lot that's just too much yeah
that's that's that's just too much I
mean that's what if if you cut down the
one piece live action it' be what 20
episodes cuz it's like about an hour I
think I think you know and I think arong
Park is definitely stronger in the anime
but I think for like the trade-off you
get for like the impact of arong Park uh
and maybe some of like Sanji AR hitting
less strongly with the anime I think
that's offset by just how streamlined
the live action is it feels way more
streamlined you know there's a lot of
fat that has been trimmed off um and
just the way that characters get
introduced I feel like cuz you know in
like the anime or the manga it's like
every character one episode at a time
gets introduced and you're like okay
when are we going on this adventure it's
a very sluggish startop whereas in the
live action we get like Nami and Zoro uh
just introduced at once and you get that
you get that all one thing I really like
you almost get that instant Chemistry
Between the like the banter between the
three of them almost like after episode
one and that's that's what I love about
one I think it makes sense though
because like especially with the manga
for instance like you know it was the
the story was just starting off so I
think Odo was still trying to get a
footing on like okay what's the like the
general Vibe I want to go with when
introducing these characters or like
what's like the most best way to do it
so I think he was like kind of testing
out a lot of things in terms of like how
to streamline that story whereas now
that it's been so established and you
know he was part of the writing team for
the live action he was just like all
right I know exactly what I did right
what I did wrong when I first started
the manga so we just cut off all the you
know [__] parts that I included in the
manga and just like make it so that I
was I was the very skeptical I was like
I don't know how well he'll know how to
translate it to film or be able to
assist with that obviously I think the
writing team crushed it uh and obviously
having his supervision probably
definitely helped it's cool I'm I'm just
glad it worked out I'm I'm happy I'm
happy we got something that's great and
uh I just hope that now it doesn't
struggle to get off and get into I
really hope it doesn't start a trend of
now I mean it's already started the
trend everyone wants to do live action
anime I mean look at M your Academia
live action is in the works look at the
look at the budget and the amount of
time and the amount of care that's to go
into to make just a good liveaction
adaptation like this is just this is UN
ungodly amounts of resources to make
this
work oh my God you H show the problem
the problem is if you if you cannot make
death note work as a live action you you
are beyond all hope of saving it is such
a an easy formula for a good thriller
like it's such a straightforward premise
that the only hard thing to kind of
really fit in is the Shinigami yeah uh
and if you can nail that the story is
laid out for you like it's I don't feel
like it should be that hard but and yet
they still [__] it up they still
[__] it up yeah which uh I'm hoping
bro if we can't get a [__] good I
mean they [__] up the first one so bad
there's a Pokemon live action coming out
too could see that working I mean I
guess Saturday show piku works it's
great yeah this one my hero Academia I'm
scared about I'm very scared of that one
I am very very scared about uh that and
it's Zack Snider as well is it Disney oh
it's Disney oh no oh no no it's not it's
Netflix okay yeah well they they nailed
the well here's the thing here's the
thing know actually okay hear me out
hear me out guys [__] maybe they can
make it
better they can improve it here here's
the deal here's the
uh Netflix now gets one good anime
adaptation Faith they get one we're all
going to be like guys hear them out yeah
and if they [__] it up we're all going
to go back to being like one piece was
one piece was a fluke it was a it was a
oneoff this doesn't happen cuz the
problem with one piece is that on paper
it shouldn't have worked like that out
of every live action I think every
single one piece fan thought it was
going to be dog oh yeah to holy [__]
yeah um and it was just one piece maybe
maybe I'm being that toxic one piece fan
right now maybe it's just maybe it's
just because maybe it's just cuz one
piece is goated you know maybe that was
the reason okay all right okay God all
right sure all right all right